قتل الرهائن الثلاثة أه الإسرائيليين
يبدو واضحا تماما أن
الأوامر أم كانت أن أي شخص داخل
منطقة النار كان من المحظور اعتباره
إرهابيا وعدم المجازفة
وأن عليهم إطلاق النار أولا وطرح
الأسئلة لاحقا وهذا ما فعله عدد من
الجنود الإسرائيليون يقولون أه على
تويتر وأم يبدو أنهم متفقون على
أن هذه هي الأوامر بأن هناك
قلقًا كبيرًا بين
الجنود الإسرائيليين وأنه يتم إعطاؤهم
أوامر بإطلاق النار أولاً وطرح الأسئلة
لاحقًا لعدم المخاطرة بأي مخاطر في النار
المنطقة، وكما تعلمون، هذا يفسر
لماذا تم إطلاق النار على هؤلاء الشباب الإسرائيليين الثلاثة الذين
خلعوا قمصانهم ورفعوا
العلم الأبيض، وحاول أحدهم
الهرب بالفعل، فذهب حول
الزاوية وتمت ملاحقته وآه وقتله
في النهاية  في محاولته
الهرب وهذه طبعا
مأساة كبيرة أه لكنها تشير أيضا إلى
المخاطر الكبيرة التي
يواجهها المدنيون الفلسطينيون في هذه
المنطقة ومن الواضح تماما أن
الاقتصاد الإسرائيلي سيتلقى ضربة كبيرة
بسبب هذه الحرب  تكلف أه 51
مليار دولار حتى الآن هذا ما أه
تقدره مجلة الإيكونوميست أه بناء على
تصريحات وزير الخزانة في
إسرائيل وأه يكلف حوالي 200
مليون دولار يوميا لمواصلة القتال
هذا لأنه تم استدعاء الكثير من الجنود
أه هم'  لقد تركوا عملهم بسبب
نقص السياحة الاستثمارية وما إلى ذلك،
حيث تركز إسرائيل على خوض هذه الحرب
في غزة الآن بالطبع
عرضت الولايات المتحدة 14 مليار دولار على إسرائيل
في حزمة مساعدات ترسل
أسلحة أخرى، ومن غير الواضح
ما إذا كانت هذه الحزمة العمرية  ستتم
الموافقة عليها من قبل الكونجرس عندما تتم
الموافقة عليها ولكن أعتقد أنه يجب على المرء أن
يفترض أنه سيتم الموافقة عليها أه في
مرحلة ما من الواضح أن الولايات المتحدة
تساعد إسرائيل بشكل كبير ولكن إسرائيل
اقتصاد ثري جدًا أم يمكنها
تحمل خوض هذه الحرب  لبعض الوقت،
لكنه يتلقى ضربة كبيرة، حيث
يتلقى الاقتصاد الإلكتروني ضربة قوية وسيؤدي
أيضًا إلى إبطاء الاستثمار في
إسرائيل لأن الكثير من الناس يرون أن إسرائيل
سوف يرون أن إسرائيل تمثل خطرًا أكبر
اليوم مما كانت عليه قبل أكتوبر
السابع